how are you doing Mindy first question  the tweet that you sent out if Brad Pitt  and laura dern win then they should date  then what I have you sent that to them  oh but do you know what right they look  good together  just gorgeous blonde so you're really  not concerned about your movie you're  really concerned about those two nothing  I know you the fun part  I'm just put to the universe exactly you  get it but you also have your Netflix  series never have I ever coming up right  tell me about give me a little tidbit  about your raunchy makes me really  worried what you Roger is going to be a  little raunchy  but it's just like real life teenage  girls how they really talk  [Music]  cannot wait for that I have teenage boy  I bet he can't wait for that  [Music]